hello and welcome to this video war mmm
I want to take them come on
okay in a recent game okay now I got you
on the board I had this this III should
be 695 blunder it was funny yeah white
is just going form yeah it's just
sacrificing pawn and trying to claim
compensation let's see if this is going
to be successful
um I have had this type of this type of
game on the board a lot more than twenty
years ago and this is usually reached
from the notable variation of the semis
laughs and I always found that these
positions are immensely complicated
okay
interesting
hmm I cannot wait I cannot think about
this for ages so trying to try to go for
a counter-attack
based on bishop takes and Knight takes
e4
so if he takes somewhere and c4 or
something I will take on c3 84
[Music]
if this is a valid approach
all right so
if I take Bishop takes 94 Bishop B form
[Music]
M if I go 85
yeah it's not good
okay I don't I am not really having you
choice
maybe I'm a I solve one or two
alternatives but
okay a five cakes on b5 and end of
variation yeah yeah my idea was c5 I
don't know if this is any good
today can play 96
this is somewhat playable it is one
thing that I wondered is if there is
some some funky piece sacrifice like
eight eggs b5 or something
I don't think it should work
I don't think so that should work
interesting this more
all right so I can definitely take and
then we should go take
before nightsticks eform
is probably not good
okay
night f2 is a completely odd thing to
play at least I don't think it's any
good
okay now I have before or take on a four
taken a fall through k1 so probably
before
you
now have
careful you may be 94 escutcheon
yeah let's do it Bishop f3 is a very
annoying move
really
I'd cook no I have was just a blunder I
was thinking what there was a what kind
of ideas there okay yeah those some
those lines here are quite interesting
if form b5 yeah now b3 a for those are
moves I don't really think if you get
this it exactly this position that you
should play nice III would rather play a
four because I mean there is no benefit
of the smooth it runs into pins as we
have seen and sometimes into B form and
I know I don't know if that is the right
way to do it I mean one argument against
this move is also Knight f6 which gets
to the gutter gambit which is total
scale a gambit where black is usually
believed to be very okay okay I went
ecigs instead and this is normally
reached via the nota bone which means
like this until the whole b5 setup only
emerges after the knight is on C for you
so wide it doesn't have a choice they
have it I don't think you should
voluntarily put it on to c3 in this
gambit situation okay so in any case
this is complicated should be to yes
any five is a typical way to play with
okay a six should be fine the engine
does not think it's fine okay so it
takes what is the deal
list this and then b3 okay
so this is the typical notable scenario
where where I should have it on
and then I have 96 okay yeah well this
is super complicated I know but that
that means that probably this is just
better for white okay he went b3 I win I
have six
DTX and that is probably not so critical
to take night tags issue before an NC 5
yeah I am surprised that the engine
actually thinks I'm better
I just okay now it goes to zero where it
is super complicated Bishop d3 is the
engine's choice
ma'am it makes some sense it's not such
an easy move to make em for you may play
I'm just answering an attack with a
counter-attack
it's very machine-like 9f2 King takes
tix this is a super crazy position on
this rather
funky nobody knows what's going on here
would be rather suspicious of blacks
position I guess which I don't know okay
so he took it
taketake 96 92 and the engine thinks I'm
just better here this is actually very
true now that I see ideally a porn is
just nicely supported by monoid and I am
a porno
Bishop d7 King e7 and I'm just been a
out okay so that is a Miss and here it's
okay well nothing special the engine
does not like 94 at all okay
so what just this year yeah it just
evaluates this as a clear advantage rook
c8 f6
maybe I am kidding but I was a little
bit unsure due to the dark square
something happening on d6 or so okay
when 94 was yeah essentially winning
because of whites reply which was lucky
yeah Bishop f4 supposed to be okay
hmm and this is this isn't even good
yeah
yeah 94 was wrong men
I didn't evaluate this right I thought I
would be fine yeah but it is not so easy
at all
he does invade on d6 own okay guys
thanks for watching